ce jour là les barea comme on les
appelle sont à la une de la presse
malgache
la veille l'équipe de madagascar est
allé battre la guinée
il ne lui reste plus qu'à remporter le
match retour à domicile pour se
qualifier pour la coupe d'afrique à
l'aéroport d'ivato à la veille de ce
match décisif
les joueurs sont accueillis en héros
thomas fontaine et le premier
réunionnais à avoir rejoint la sélection
malgache alors qu'il évolue aujourd'hui
au stade de reims en ligue 1
il a acquis en 2010 est la nationalité
malgache et a rejoint les barea
depuis quatre autres réunionnais
l'intimité
le saint-pierrois william gros est
attaquant à vitré en ligue 2 ryan
raveloson joue à trois et jérôme mombris
à grenoble il ne manque que romain
metanire qui rejoindra l'équipe demain
n'est pas devenu mythe et des jeunes
[Musique]
m
elle le lendemain matin les joueurs dans
encore dans ces petits bungalows à
quelques centaines de mètres du stade où
ils joueront tout à l'heure il est 7h et
des centaines de spectateurs se pressent
déjà dans les gradins thomas fontaine
partage la chambre de william gros c'est
la case réunionnaise n'a la côte au
sénat romain hommage aux héros michael
ryan thomas se dirige à présent vers la
salle de restaurant pour le petit
déjeuner font jour
depuis gourmandise on ne peut avoir deux
tie domi chic force au ghana ces lacs
d'afrique
déjà ça et puis même de rentrer dans
l'histoire du football malgache enjeux
de fou on retient mais pour thomas
il reste une grosse incertitude car il a
écopé de deux cartons jaunes lors des
précédentes rencontres et il n'est pas
sûr de jouer aujourd'hui c'est
l'entraîneur nicolas dupuis qui lui
annonce la mauvaise nouvelle thomas
accuse le coup il ne jouera pas cette
après midi un match qu'ils aient
historique arrive alors roma metanire le
dernier des cinq réunionnais très proche
de thomas pris ce qu'ils jouent ensemble
arras romain qui arrive un peu plus tard
que les autres car il s'est marié trois
jours plus tard thomas pas trop dégoûté
de paris
[Applaudissements]
avec des piqûres a mérité le bronze
sourit à tout est jamais aurait suspendu
pascal razak lui et malgaches mais ils
jouent à la saint-pierroise
et comme les autres joueurs il n'en
revient pas de voir la foule déjà
présentes
[Musique]
c'est que tu montes et on vit de ce
matelas des stocks étant vides soit lé
peuple malgache aurait définitivement va
le faire
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas rien
quand les joueurs font leur entrée dans
le stade pour un dernier entraînement
l'ambiance monte encore d'un cran merci
pour ce moment que je suis un rapport
pour le prier le dernier entraînement de
préparation baigner le match est venu la
forme santé
[Musique]
après l'entraînement nous nous asseyons
quelques instants avec thomas fontaine
pour qu'il nous raconte comment il s'est
retrouvé embarqué dans cette aventure
n'hésitez pas trop trop trop pour ce
qu'on voit la marge de la réunion
mais revenir avant tout malgache et si
du côté des grands parents qui sa rivale
madagascar nathalie fontaine on va en
mer la motivation c'est le sport c'est
aussi retrouver trace il est le sport et
la racine en tout cas c'est pas pour
l'argent
pas du tout si des plages on y pense que
la bonté pense peut-être sommes à
montmagny le côté humain et comme idiome
écrire une histoire de la vie d'une
pièce albert il est pas donné à tout le
monde où les pierres bleues en train de
faire
franchement
le match aujourd'hui ses joues à vous de
vous rendre en pleine campagne
car le stade de tananarive a été
suspendu après les graves incidents du
match madagascar sénégal au mois de
septembre
les spectateurs arrivent à pied en moto
ou en taxi le match va bientôt commencer
[Applaudissements]
dans le bus les joueurs réunionnais
chante avec les autres mais quelques
minutes plus tard dans les vestiaires
l'ambiance est tout à coup beaucoup plus
concentrés bonjour
pour le
et
le chien
c'est la partie est
c'est dangereux
[Musique]
suspendu thomas fontaine a pris place
dans les tribunes et c'est parti pour 90
minutes
rapidement les malgaches se créer une
première occasion mais l'attaquant est
signalé hors jeu
oui
finalement c'est juste avant la mi temps
que madagascar ouvre la marque tir au
ras du sol après une belle échappée de
l'ailier gauche j
[Applaudissements]
pendant tout le match les réunionnais
metanire et mombris sont parmi les plus
actifs william gros les rejoint en fin
de partie
[Applaudissements]
il ne reste que quelques minutes et on
commence à y croire
salon attend la table la can comprenez
la coupe d'afrique des nations cette
fois ça y est les malgaches la joueront
pour la première fois de leur histoire
nova la cad lui 8e ciel oui mais divers
humour oui c'est dur à une ambiance
extraordinaire les masses moment là même
l'envoyé spécial de la télévision
réunionnaise se laisse gagner par
l'euphorie générale
je vous le disais 5 réunionnais et
participent à cette aventure nous
propose d'antan quelques-unes de leurs
réactions à l'issue de ce match
c'est l'histoire d'un jeu magie n'est
jamais moi j'aurai deux années là ça
c'est le monsieur de monsieur parce que
c'est s'est vendu des titres immobiliers
sauce et degrés c au plus au dessus je
sais c'est une grosse joie c'est une
grande émotion
ouais c'est un grand jour un moment et
jusqu'au but
on a du mal à réaliser mais bon c'est
quand ce qu'on a fait j'espère qu'on a
rendu un peu comme adversaire de
pierre et voilà c'est une belle histoire
aussi entre réunion et madagascar
oui bah ça s'est confirmé tous rire et
montrer que ce soir on avait le même
sens les malgaches ensemble puis on les
malgaches ensemble exactement combat
parce que en ce moment tu penses à ta
grand mère mais ouais normal
voilà le père au programme deux pays
rentrent en terrasse
la femme est aussi bas
témoin les fantasmes d'un point de mode
et brenda l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
et la suite ce sera en juin 2019 la
coupe d'afrique des nations au cameroun
[Applaudissements]